[Music]
and welcome back to careful boys
everybody we've got silent mic over here
where did you get silent from what yeah
um
in the gym i used to train at uh long
story short i feel like i kind of got
some uh mixed personality stuff going on
and part of me is really like shy as
schizophrenia no i'm not diagnosed i
just got like different modes you know
cool and oh we all yeah yeah yeah joe
definitely does
yeah joe's got full throttle and full
throttle
now i'm relaxed just got full throttle
and late to the conversation
i was process i call that processing
okay come on man so i just observed what
was going on i was the youngest dude
smallest dude at the gym uh and that's
kind of when we started making youtube
content you were the smallest dude at
the gym yeah three they're all like 300
pounds i was like 23 they're all over
30. it was just a different time
different time that's big yeah
how did you get into that [ __ ] oh which
is even funnier i don't even think you
better one of my best friends lisa and
like powerlifting now is cool everybody
does it but back then it's not that long
ago like 10 12 years
chicks didn't really power lift and one
of my friends a little blonde chick
from south africa one of my best friends
my whole life literally googled like
hardcore gym and she ended up at super
training oh and then i was i was
training at just a commercial gym
coaching work and whatever and she's
like yo you want to take this [ __ ]
seriously you want to learn you got to
come down here and then i guess yeah
besides her i was the smallest person
there youtube contest started coming out
it's doing uh they're filming me in
interviews or whatever um maybe they
didn't know my last name just because
you're a part of it you're part of the
the crew that i was training so they
want to put you in the yeah well i went
hard like i went a little harder and
sometimes i showed up hard in the paint
dog
yeah but some people just didn't know
it's that italian dick oh we're already
i'm super buffing yeah but for people
who don't work out yet yeah what does
that mean to go harder than paint uh i
was kind of joking but not but like we
trained in a team um so there's like 15
of us some people are just like [ __ ] off
it's like every group you get right like
some people like go through the motions
yeah some people take it serious and
some people don't probably say with
dancing right like you go to a classroom
he's just saying that some people
[ __ ] saw kat being successful yeah
and i wasn't the strongest my enemies i
was the weakest by far but i just worked
mediocrity um so i think that's why they
put me in the youtube videos and then
they gave me the nickname and then
instagram youtube all that kind of
started so i just kind of because you
were quiet in the videos oh i was in the
first one i was a little nervous because
you're like so far from being silent
ever since i met you yeah but i'm
comfortable with you guys is your last
name mugatu's uh i like mugatu
that's my instagram yeah i just like too
so i was like oh your last name is [ __ ]
that because he designs clothes you know
zoolander right yes
lander zoolander because that design is
your prime minister
exactly
that's it
yeah that's kind of cool how did you get
into powerlifting it's such an
interesting and niche sport uh mostly
just because uh when you start to start
to google like how to be faster how to
be stronger how to like dunk a
basketball or something again again i'm
a professional athlete yeah like what's
the difference between powerlifting and
like lifting so powerlifting is a sport
of three lifts uh squat
bench and deadlift and you just compete
to lift those one rep max as heavy as
you can yeah yeah it's heavy real sport
right dancing's not really a sport
is dance in a sport
no no no no first of all dancing is a
sport it's not about it it is it's both
no you can't be both no you choose one
that's exactly right we are not about
martial arts it's literally both no i
think marshall i think practicing
martial arts is an art competing when
you fight someone is a sport but that's
both though no
i mean that's literally both you just
described no because when you're not
performing when you're you're competing
against somebody you are performing oh
you know the difference between this
you're not performing when i'm beating
up like let's say uh [ __ ] just
because it's entertaining i'm performing
let me tell you something now just
because it's entertaining or there's
observers doesn't mean you're a
performer
i think you're just being insecure
because you have no art in what you do
no i went to art school for 13 years you
have no art in what you do let me speak
for every soccer mom out there oh [ __ ]
you're not my artist no i'm an artist
where's the music or the soul
hey mike's a pretty good dancer that was
actually pretty good
i feel like he changes the same cruise
bar
yeah bart told me you're the dude with
the mask
yeah
totally
the most successful
you don't know
you don't know swag i don't know how
successful this [ __ ] goes
i do this for gas money and food right
that's about the only thing that was
left
speaking of success which i don't have
um okay so back to it yeah power lifting
is mainly three
yep three exercises the squat the bench
in the middle as opposed to what you see
in the olympics that's olympic
weightlifting or weightlifting for short
and they hit the clean and jerk and then
uh the snatch yeah and then there's
bodybuilding is is powerlifting in the
olympics no they're trying to get it
there it won't ever happen okay why not
because
uh mike's a hater there's too many
federations it's too broke it's more
broken up than boxing if you guys know
about oh really yeah and then there's a
big steroid that's one of the reasons
why it karate took so damn long to get
into olympics because it's even older
than taekwondo yeah like that like like
ten minutes too many damn federation is
it isn't boxing and the limits kind of
like the best amateurs to go there and
then if they kill it there they kind of
go to pro boxing not really because the
sport is very different from a
professional level to amateur level
because amateur level it's all about
scoring points
but then and seeing how many uh punches
you could land within a form that's very
olympic style that's olympic style but
pro boxing is like the the game is just
completely different because the
pretense changes like this because
there's a performance factor to it no
there's no performance yes you're trying
to knock knocking out is more important
there's an entertainment factor maybe no
but it's to win it like you have longer
periods it's not based on you how many
punches you land on so where is where is
the same conversation concept of
weightlifting the olympics versus like
uh powerlifting so weightlifting there's
like one national federation and then uh
one world federation okay um and so it's
like so the olympics is like you guys
got your [ __ ] together come on
but then if it's uh if it's like you
guys are too scattered yeah and y'all
dramatic we don't want none of that
[ __ ] more drugs are common where
like if you're weightlifting um and you
are registered and all the stuff you
could get random drug tests uh no one's
ever gonna drug test me apart because
we're juicing out of our brains
yeah they just it's not organized enough
bart have you ever tried steroids no i
really want to yeah really what do you
feel like you really this isn't like
it's a passion like a bucket list
because how people on steroids talk
about steroids
sound like yeah it sounds like your head
to neverland have you spoke with people
off steroids like they've been doing it
for years and then they [ __ ] regret
it because you're talking to people that
are on it nope and they're still
benefiting the friends that have gotten
off and we know someone
they look they talk about
the old days like it's the [ __ ] good
old thing but i do think they're
romantic we talk about ecstasy and we go
when we used to rain i think it's
probably simple actually we have had him
on alex yeah so even when alex talks
about it he's like [ __ ] i remember he's
just
squat 500 for riffs yeah but like all
memory all memory you always remember
the good [ __ ] yeah you don't remember
like damn i had hella acne
my testicles were the size of [ __ ]
eminem's like you don't remember that
you remember like damn i just added on
weight
yeah but they all always talk about
can't get sick immunity is through the
roof [ __ ] you only need to sleep four
hours because you're [ __ ] crazy
optimized and you're crazy strong sounds
pretty cool you eat a pizza and you
magically get a six pack it sounds like
your crazy ex who's really good at
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah dude it's fun and
then it was like oh [ __ ] and then as you
go through it you forget all the
downsides of it yeah of course what are
the doubts going through anything and
forgetting the downside
no steroids depending on what you take
you can have
crazy like wet dreams night sweats that
sounds awesome
heart attack yeah impotence okay heart
attack impotence i don't want anything
if you take one thing it's gonna [ __ ] up
another so like if you're trying to get
jackson strong like you won't be able to
go up two stairs without breathing
you're like coughing or the opposite
like if you do a bunch of conditioning
type [ __ ] like some epo your muscles
probably just won't work what about the
one that just like makes you feel alive
like i don't think anyone makes i'll
probably just a little bit test let's
say i'm balding right now if i take it
does that bring my hair back
oh no
it'll take it from your head and put it
on your shoulders it'll accelerate it he
grows it from here and it takes it away
it kind of does it gets the shoulders
i don't know if you were going to take a
steroid like
like the most optimal one or as far as
like to your goals and whatever yeah
i don't know that you can get in
southern california what i do with 36
hours
is that it was like more legal and less
taboo so then they could do more
research then i'd be like because all of
it's still bro talk yeah even though i
have smart friends that do it they don't
really know it's all like you could go
to the mexican pharmacy yeah we i know i
could get it i mean it's easy it's like
you gotta plug it's cool you can find it
but i just don't think even my smartest
meathead friend knows really what's
going on even though they have a lot of
so you're a person of the doses and what
it should be scientifically me
personally i got like mental [ __ ] i
ain't trying to get angry i try to live
as happy as i can and i know a lot of
people
for sure for sure and they say like oh
if you're angry and then you take you
get angrier but like what do you know
that's just like bro talk like they
don't really know i think yeah it's 10
me and my 10 buddies that happened too
we're like okay what about we put it on
a thousand people it's usually one buddy
though right right right what's the
steroid that i can take or i eat
whatever i want and i don't get fat i
don't think that's ever like a real
thing but it will help you build muscle
just diet pills yeah dude just do fat
meth yeah yeah meth methods are really
good that's probably the best but do you
even have appetite when you do math nah
not like meth
oh so bad it was so good no it's just
bad that's just crypto talking today's
video is brought to you by hello fresh
okay what in the world is this hello
freshy thingy well you get fresh
pre-packaged ingredients straight to
your doorstep so you could assemble this
right in the comfort of your own home
and you can get delicious yummy
healthy foods have you ever tried making
something and you only need one of
something but you go to the grocery
store and it comes in a giant bag
and now you're like what am i gonna do
with all these goddamn beets i got a
whole bag of onions dude a whole bag
every day i'm putting onions into
everything i'm eating see and that's the
problem a lot of people they got a lot
of food waste so that's what's one of
the cool things about the pre
portion packages where per meal whether
it's for one person two people four
people however big your household is
it's pre-portioned so that it's the
perfect amount of carrots to ingredients
to whatever so you don't have any food
waste at all but not only that
i like the fact that there's not that
much food waste but the cleanup is
easier man you don't have that much
stuff you don't have that much seasoning
you don't have all this crap and for me
you know i'm a bit of a minimalist so
like i do like it where you don't have a
bunch of crap everywhere it's just
easier this way yeah we cook together as
a family all the time it's fun it's just
a bonding activity and everything you
need is right in the package and you
have to worry about spilling the whole
bottle of cinnamon and all over the
place because the cinnamon will come in
a little packet it's perfectly
pre-portioned for what you need so if
you want to give hello fresh a try it's
america's number one meal kit go to
hellofresh.com
off the record 14 to get up to 14 free
meals plus 3 free gifts that's
hellofresh.com
off the record 14 to get up to 14 free
meals and it's the holiday seasons
there's all kinds of yummy stuff like
pumpkin spice everything so make sure
you go check that out up to 14 free
meals plus three free gifts oh it's my
favorite yeah
yeah no but i do want to bring it back
and remind you the dancers are both
athletes and okay explain it a little
better
okay first of all i would say the
similar argument that i made to martial
arts is that like when you're practicing
it's a really bad argument no i think i
think that's right i think that's fair i
totally agree with barbara and lebron
doing something just as violent as
graceful isn't that art and sport
together how is him this is violent
that's knocking a guy out if you okay
like me taking a [ __ ] his art because i
produce no no no no no no listen listen
artist's objective yeah yeah so if you
want by the way i will take it
personally if you don't uh accept at
least the conversation of what i present
then i i think that you are totally
judging without knowing as long as you
bring me into the crew dude perfect
perfect how do you preface that you guys
need a token white guy
we have two um
and they're very good for illegal cases
in marketing oh then you get three we
also have one black guy and that helps
solve everything oh that guy's from
sacramento yeah you know ace right yeah
okay so that being said ace that's cool
yeah his name is josh but his last name
is ventura so his nickname is ace that's
sweet
his actual name is josh ventura
okay so that being said yeah so let's
say in like taekwondo right yeah in that
one or or many or even karate there's
like katas or
there's like forms yeah and then there's
also actual like technique for sparring
i don't know what words you said but
i've heard about this uh there isn't one
that's what's in the olympics right
those are the cottages
oh really because they talk [ __ ] on that
right yeah because you kind of the
fighters [ __ ] on it
it's art not fighting
the kata's is like a routine talking
[ __ ]
maybe not talking [ __ ] maybe not talking
[ __ ] they say it's art like even rogan
makes that argument i think i think a
lot of people do but like when you watch
it we talked about this on here when you
watch the kata's being done part of you
is like all right what is this it's
figure skating art or sport to you
that's probably also because you're the
type of guy who goes into like a a
modern art museum and you're like i
don't get this oh that's not true no
that's me that's mean dude because it's
mean for you to look at concepts and be
like this is weak no it's not that it's
weak it's you're a mean guy
i mean i don't know i think he's a nice
guy what i'm saying
the practice of katas i totally
understand why somebody would do that
right it's gets you better awareness
it's like a form it's a designated form
play fighting i believe pretty much but
it's like it's it's good for connection
it's good for [ __ ] like
understanding the technique and going
through a flow and shadow boxing with
somebody else exactly but you don't want
to think about fighting but you you
won't see shadow boxing competitions you
know what i mean they should be it's
like air band huh
but that's what makes it an art
it's a guitar hero
the fact that you don't compete with
those things in that way and then you
can appreciate and respect it for
the things that are beyond what you see
but when you add judging to it then it
becomes inherently a sport which is
exactly why dancing is both art and
sport
you literally just backed me up
no but i never said it wasn't a sport or
dance i'm just saying i can i can have a
judge there for two homeless people
fighting against
sports
it's called bum fights that's true but
it wasn't a sport that's for sure with
bart's reference at like
lebron moving in an aesthetic way
because he's a good athlete but we think
that's aesthetic because he's good
athletes and that's what athletes look
like then yeah everything but what is
the definition of a sport uh i literally
just did on this on a podcast i'm saying
what i'm saying is this
uh
lebron and someone else can both shoot a
three-point shot right yeah the goal and
purpose of it is the same they both
increased the score by three points yeah
that's the sport side of it the art side
is how they do it that's what i'm saying
so if that if you want to say that i'll
say i agree then everything's art and
sport
soccer football
and then i'll say like okay and then the
world is boring no soccer is incapable
of being an art no way dude a little
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
dude of flopping man-to-man human human
you're honestly thinking that
that soccer [ __ ] that soccer and dance
are the same level
of athleticism and artistry no but i was
saying if you want to take the
lebron james case yeah then i'm going to
say that's that that's the same thing
yeah are you a fan of kobe i'm a fan of
all sports i love dancing
he doesn't know anything i love dancing
music more than i like sports you guys
seen this have you guys seen this dance
and other art forms and athletics in
alignment with one another
well um there was a there was a year we
played uh
indiana pacers in the finals i rolled my
ankle really bad j.l rose stepped under
me on purpose
five he admits it now finally and rolled
my ankle really really bad i came back
finished the series
but i couldn't touch a basketball until
mid-september which was driving me crazy
i couldn't train
but i looked at this was like the tenth
time i rolled my ankle in one season
so i'm looking at that i'm saying okay i
gotta address that
and so being that i couldn't get on the
basketball court um
what i did was i took tap dancing
lessons okay no kidding i took a tap and
it changed my rhythm and my approach to
the game i was able to change speeds
when i came back the following season
um you know i think dancers um
put
way more strainer in their body than
athletes do
and i think there's a lot that can be
learned from that my daughter took
ballet for several years and i would sit
there in the class right and i didn't
know what i was getting into i don't
know anything about ballet right but i'm
sitting there in the class and i'm
watching her and watching get the first
position the second position i'm sorry
i'm learning the structure and the rules
that go along with that and as athletes
there's a lot to be learned from that
because if you simply go out there and
perform and play
and you'll be great every now and then
but if you play with structure if you
understand the rules that come along
with that the discipline that comes
along with that
then you reach another level
all right listen to this wait listen to
this yeah that means that he was listen
to this okay and that dance could be
beneficial for athletes and i would say
[ __ ] yeah i could yeah i took
interpretive dance for 12 years okay
listen to this okay did you really swear
to god hey listen to this okay so no i
never did that and it's not athletic no
sport in athletic is different
sport and athletic is different but god
damn it listen to this dancers around
[ __ ]
listen hold on this is gonna answer
everything yeah cause i just did this
competitive
it's competitive physical activity or
game so it has to be competitive so in
the act of a competition like abdc or
whatever in that dance is a sport
because it's a physical you got certain
but if it's just self-expression yeah so
that's just art didn't i literally just
say that so didn't you guys literally
just confirm that dancers are both
artists and athletes it depends what
they do in context didn't kobe just say
that dancing is great for exercise did
he say that he's a tap dancer
you thought it was a great warm-up i
think but also i don't think i don't
think anyone you're tying you're tying
sports athlete and i'm not i don't think
anyone's saying dancers are not athletes
whatever
in the beginning this conversation no no
it was sport not a sport because i think
there's sports where you're not an
athlete let me make it really clear golf
i think golfers are not the best i just
don't understand why what you guys are
arguing against what i might be saying
we're not arguing no i'm into semantics
and you're not i'm going to go i'm going
to use the semantics which is why i'm
going to go
you're an athlete and an artist and i do
sports you do with dance but not all
dancers do dancing is not a sport
you are a you compete dance is a sport
for anybody who chooses to recognize to
compete what about so therefore i'm
allowed to say dance is a sport you're
not allowed to tell me dancing sport if
i compete with you you compete with it
yeah so i'm saying dance is a sport yeah
so it's not wrong dance can be
dance can be but dancing is not
semantics no no the semantics says
dancing is not a sport that's correct
what about tickets i would say dancing
is not or is a sport i said dance is a
sport
i'm gonna go
i will go to ten performing arts centers
and i'm gonna tag them with dance is not
a sport
and i want dancers with hope in their
eyes to go up there and be like oh
that's what i'm gonna do now just
because you think dance is a sport
it's like saying like acting's a sport
is it no but when you try out for
something you're competing against
somebody in a basis if there is a game
behind it it is no it could be yeah but
i think dance is an art but that you do
computer physical activity that like
pushes the bounds of human experience in
the acting part i don't think you have
to push the bounds of humans experiences
stunt auditions oh yes no even just
acting you're moving you're moving your
body
do you have a better argument with me
against china or esports yeah but now
with esports poker and all that why that
is considered a sport is because of the
game aspect of it so that's why in dance
it there has to be a game aspect there
has to be a competitive aspect why
b-boys and b-girls are going and no
one's arguing against that that is a
sport it's a sport there yeah i agree
yeah so why are you guys talking to me
like you're arguing like you need to
convince me because your blanket
statement that all dances that's why i
didn't blanket statement that i was just
saying something that you denied it
therefore i had to back up the fact that
it's not it can be yes yes it can be my
own file i'm talking about boxing lebron
james
yeah i would love this one a little bit
it can be for sure lebron's artiste
[Music]
[Music]
foreign